my advice as far as like when it comes  to whatever it is you want to ride or  material you want to find or a story you  want to tell or you want to do  is  what's a movie you want to see what is a  movie that some you know it's like you  know uh uh uh what is it you want to  contribute all right uh and and make it  maybe just even slightly a little less  about you yourself I'm assuming most of  you guys haven't made a feature yet all  right so but there's a lot of features  that have been made before you there's a  whole lot of movies you could see  a whole lot of movies you could watch  without you  what's the movie that we have never seen  because you haven't made it  and make that movie